riding an exercise bike can help burn
calories increase strength and reach
fitness goals
they start by making the bike frame
which includes the handlebars saddle
posts and flywheel housing an employee
places all the parts in a welding
fixture the welding system is
computerized the fixture moves the parts
into position and a robot accurately
welds the joints of the frame it takes
20 welds to link all the parts of the
bike frame at the next station a machine
shapes the handlebars and saddle posts
to the correct profile then a worker
polishes the welds with the wire brush
next they apply a black plastic finish
to the metal this process is called
powder coating an employee applies a
batali decal of the company name to the
powder coated frame he inserts the
bearing for the peddle crank axle and
gently taps it into place with a hammer
he attaches a circuit board to the base
it will control the resistance of the
flywheel he threads the wiring through
the hollow frame and out the handlebar
post
he drills holes in the saddle bar tubing
then he installs the post and adjustable
locking screw he installs a temporary
clamping lever on the flywheel framework
which will be used to tension the
transmission belt
he installs the bike saddle then he uses
a hydraulic system to press an axle and
bearing into the center of the flywheel
he places a product name decal on the
flywheel the cast-iron flywheel is the
heart of the bike at about 40 pounds
it's heavy enough to stabilize the bike
during the stationary ride he loops the
transmission belt around the flywheel
axle then mounts the flywheel to the
framework he installs magnetic brakes
and wires them to a bike computer the
brakes allow the rider to control the
resistance during their ride he connects
the pulley disc to the front of the bike
then he loops the other end of the
transmission belt around the pulley disc
he uses a clamping lever to pull the
belt tight he strums it and measures the
sound to confirm the tension is right
the next worker removes the clamp and
places the bike in a test station
it spins the flywheel and applies
resistance a computer analyzes the bikes
performance another employee wires the
switches for increasing and decreasing
resistance
she touched the wiring inside the
handlebars she attached his switches to
the outside for easy access during the
ride she folds the lower half of the
resistance wiring up and installs the
wiring sleeve in between the handlebars
she screws the bracket to the handlebar
housing then she connects the wires to
the ride computer and attaches it to the
bracket she opens the computer and plugs
the main power cable into the back then
she reinstalls the computer's back panel
this completes the handlebar assembly
the next worker encases the transmission
belt and electrical parts in a plastic
housing
he attaches the pedals to the axle then
he places plastic caps on the ends and
hammers them into place
he packages the bike and handlebar
assembly separately this exercise bike
is now ready to ride
it may be stationary but when it comes
to fitness this bike should help riders
go the distance